[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in peter king
football morning in america and nbc
sports columnist
good morning pete how are you
everything's going great dan how about
yourself
we're great you're back from vacation
ready to hit the road
covering training camp um the
top headline today in the nfl in your
opinion is what
you know what'll happen with aaron
rodgers it's going to continue to be the
top headline he's due to report to
packers camp tomorrow as
all veteran players are uh
i don't assume he's going to report to
camp but who knows he could make it like
brett favre
in 2008 when farv said i'm gonna
push their hand i'm gonna you know and
i'm gonna put pressure on them
i'm gonna report and make it hot on them
uh
so you just don't know there's a news
blackout from all sides on it
it's very hard to get anybody to talk
about it over the weekend
even on deep background so we'll see
what happens
yeah i was going to bring that up that
you know you're trying to get
information
and it's difficult to get any
information because
it feels like aaron rodgers is the
person with all the information and
nobody else has a take on it or willing
to say something that might incite
something here
yeah i think it's aaron rodgers and his
agent david dunn who coincidentally
uh was the agent for the last star
quarterback
who really fought his way out of a place
and that was carson palmer
uh you know a decade and a half ago when
he said i'm not playing for the bengals
anymore
i'll retire and look carson palmer
was not going to play for the bengals
anymore but
but you know he got fortunate at the
trading deadline that year because the
raiders remember that year
jason campbell was the raiders
quarterback he got hurt
the raiders desperately needed a
quarterback al davis said we'll do
whatever it takes to get
carson palmer it's a little bit
different in this particular case
because if you want to get aaron rodgers
you know
that it's going to take about two or
three times as much
uh as it did to get carson palmer back
in the day
and i just don't think as of this moment
as we sit here on july
26th that the packers still are even
entertaining the thought of trading them
but if they do
as i wrote this morning they must
get 2021 value in return
which is why i proposed multiple
first-round draft picks and
something like drew locke and jerry judy
uh from denver for aaron rodgers most
people would say well that's not enough
well you're not exactly in the best
position to trade right now
if you got a question for rogers and had
that opportunity
what would you ask him what are you
gonna do
i mean because look dan you know the
funny thing about all this is
you know aaron went on uh with kenny
mayne
what was it now a couple of months ago i
guess and he said i love the fans
i love the team i love the coaches i
love jordan love
i love the history i love everything
about green bay
left unsaid was that he doesn't love
brian goodakins
and i guess he doesn't love mark murphy
the team president
so you know honestly my
my olive branch in this situation
is basically rogers agreeing to play one
more year with them
and then the packers agreed to trade him
to one of four teams in the afc
after this seat that rogers could
designate after
this season and then uh let's let's all
move on to the next crisis of the day
tom pelicero is reporting that uh the
texans are now willing to listen
and have been for some time with offers
for deshaun watson
but i'm i'm just trying to figure out
the bargaining power
uh can i give you a lesser offer um
you have that sense of uncertainty here
with deshaun watson pete how do you
think this plays out with the texans
i just don't think it makes any sense
whatsoever to trade them right now
or to even entertain thoughts about
trading them
because unless you're the philadelphia
eagles and say we'll give you three ones
and
two players right now for a guy
who probably isn't going to play the
first half of this season
if he's going to play this season at all
you know you got to have
full education about a player before you
would
consider trading for him especially
making a mega trade
what happens if this case you know drags
on
for months and months or maybe into next
year
i mean if you're the philadelphia eagles
right now
and and and deshaun watson is going to
be traded and you find out that
say the carolina panthers are going to
trade the moon and the stars for them
i still wouldn't go nuts in trade form
because look there's probably only a 15
20
chance that jalen hurts is good enough
to be your long-term guy we all know
that
but they're giving them this year and
then they're gonna have the opportunity
maybe in next year to take
a really good rookie quarterback who we
don't know a year ago
zach wilson was a total nobody and he
ends up being the second pick in the
draft so don't tell me
that the uh you know the quarterback
crop next year stinks
i i don't first of all i have no idea
whether it stinks or not
they got to play this year people will
emerge
this is a bad time to trade deshaun
watson
and to trade for deshaun watson but the
commissioner's exempt list
does that help the situation because
deshaun watson's there
and i don't know if he's showing up a
you don't want to be fine but b
you sort of want to be a distraction so
they
say all right we don't want you on the
field what do you think could happen
with the commissioner's exempt list here
look if he's put on the commissioner's
exempt list then then
obviously then he doesn't have to show
up he won't show up
um hey look and it's also within the
texans purview
to have desean watson report
and for you to tell watson you know nick
casario david cully to tell him hey just
go home
we don't want you here and you know
we're not going to find you and have him
be
one of the 90 men on the roster
but he's just not participating in
practice and so
look you know it's it's a wide
open field in houston i just think it
makes no sense to trade him or to trade
for him right now
he's back from vacation peter king
football morning in america
column and nbc sports as well
wednesday you'll be in nevada thursday
with the niners
friday the cowboys saturday the rams
which of those teams is most intriguing
you know in my opinion the raiders uh
and look the niners are very very close
to them but the raiders
you know this is year four of john
gruden dan
he's 19 and 29 i mean
you know that's not what you're paying
10 million dollars a year for
and so you know at some point
the players who john gruden and mike
mayok
have brought into the fold have to play
better than 19 and 29. he knows that
they all know that
the 49ers really interest me just from
the standpoint of
i i think they're when i rated the teams
one to 32
they're very very high on my list
they're number five
and my feeling about them is if they are
relatively healthy on defense this year
uh i think they're going to be playing
deep into january and maybe into
february
so i really like those two teams just
for the drama sake
and obviously wherever jerry jones is
uh wherever the cowboys are is gonna be
fun
um the rams is it's an interesting
situation because you get stafford
and now he got now he gets talent around
him
he's got a couple of marquee defensive
players he's got pretty good offense
even though you lose cam acres
i wonder if the expectation level is
getting a little too high
pete and we haven't even gotten you know
started with cam
look i am the worst person to pick
to predict futures bets and things like
that
like if you would ask me before the
baseball season
bet on one thing this year i would have
taken the under on the boston red sox
victory 78.
i i i i what are they doing you know
with the best record in the american
league i
i have no idea but you know that's how
much i know
but if you ask me this year who would be
your first quarterback
in fantasy football this year it'd be
matthew stafford and one of the reasons
is what we saw the other day when cam
a when cam acres got hurt now
they're into the flotsam and jetsam area
of their roster at running back
and i just think what's gonna i think
matthew stafford
will lead the nfl this year in passing
yards
and attempts and so
you heard it here first he's going to
throw for 5 000 yards
he's going to throw it 40 times a game
go out and buy matthew stafford in your
fantasy league
paulie were we rolling on that so we can
bring that back to peter late in the
season yes please
absolutely what's that what's that
website where they bring back horrible
cold freezing cold takes yeah
yeah right that'll be that'll be that
one when matthew stafford
uh you know gets benched in week 11
because he's not playing well
yeah do you think expectation level
well i don't know what the cowboys
expectation level is but it feels like
the browns expectation level
is really really high out of those two
teams why wouldn't it be dan
why wouldn't it be they had the ball
uh against the kansas city chiefs
in kansas city in the fourth quarter
they had him
with the ability to drive down the field
and go ahead
i mean if baker mayfield that would have
been the baker mayfield moment
okay and and they didn't do it and again
everybody can say well you know
uh patrick mahomes didn't play in the
fourth quarter yeah he didn't
but you know what in the first three
quarters they didn't put the cleveland
browns away
and in fact the cleveland browns played
the chiefs
tougher than the buffalo bills did last
year the bills lost by 14 and nine
points
in their two meetings but you know as i
wrote today i mean tremendous optimism
in both places buffalo and cleveland
dan this is the first time
since uh you know in over 30 years that
each team
has been this good entering a season
and how about the last time that each
team won a playoff game
uh in a season like they did last year
1964. went on back-to-back days in
cleveland and buffalo
they won the uh afl and nfl
uh championship games so i i
buy that they deserve both
teams deserve to be hyped up pretty good
what about dallas
i mean i don't know we talk about dallas
every year
i love jerry jones i like he had a quote
in his opening press conference
about optimism that i thought was
fantastic
why be pessimistic i'm optimistic every
year because
i see the glasses being half full and
you know what
if if they get great play
early on from micah parsons and a really
good group
of linebackers i mean they are as deep
at linebacker uh as as really as
any team is dan and if if micah parsons
is
is really good they could have the
ability to hold teams in the low 20s
if they do that and dak prescott can
play 17 games
then they're gonna be pretty good as of
now i
i i give washington the very slight edge
in the division but
i could see dallas winning 11 games last
call for roethlisberger
i would think but look he he heeded the
calls
he hated his body's calls you know when
you saw the picture of him walking into
training camp
looking like ben roethlisberger 2008
instead of what he looked like last year
which was he was just he just got too
big last year
um you know he looks good and and dan
if you listen to him talk now it's
almost like the offensive coordinator is
matt canada you know this guy who nobody
in america has ever heard of
but i would say ben roethlisberger
while not being co-coordinator he's
gonna have a lot to say
with what they run how often they run it
and i
i think he's going to be at matt
canada's side
and so this is going to be a
roethlisberg season
if the steelers can have one last hurrah
with ben roethlisberger this is it i i
just i just
really wonder with the offensive line
you know having lost the two gigantic
members three really if you count
villanueva but you lose
their best offensive lineman david de
castro and you lose the center
that was the leader not only of that
line but of that team
in marquis pouncey i mean
you know is ben going to be running for
his life or
you know are they going to be solid up
there we'll see
if the rams win the super bowl you're
our first guest on that monday
if if the rams missed the playoffs
you're our first guest
on that monday we're gonna i gotta be
your first guest when
when matthew stafford is benched for
john doe in week 11.
thank you peter uh safe travels this
week all right hey thanks a lot dan have
a good week
that's peter king working on a little
sleep there football morning
in america pete will be on the road
covering the raiders on wednesday the
niners thursday cowboys friday
saturday the rams and then he comes home
and he
writes his column